[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen Norbert Lehmann hat
Fußball für Sie schönen guten Abend und
wir beginnen mit der Nachricht des
Abends
der Kanzler hat entschieden die drei
deutschen Atomkraftwerke sollen bis
April nächsten Jahres weiterlaufen
dürfen
wieder russische Luftangriffe Kamikaze
Drohnen und Raketen schlagen in mehreren
ukrainischen Städten ein
Lesen und Rechnen schwach eine neue
Studie zeigt das Corona tiefe Spuren an
den Grundschulen hinterlässt
[Musik]
der Kanzler hat ein Machtwort gesprochen
im Streit um eine Verlängerung der
AKW-Laufzeiten vor wenigen Minuten wurde
ein Statement von Scholz veröffentlicht
dass er von seiner Richtlinienkompetenz
Gebrauch macht vor allem und die Grünen
und die FDP hatten sich vollkommen
verhakt bei dem Thema fragen wir nach
bei Theo call in Berlin Theo was hat der
Kanzler genau entschieden julia hat sich
in diesem uns jetzt vorliegenden
Schreiben klar für den Weiterbetrieb
aller drei AKW entschieden also auch für
das Kraftwerk im Emsland die Grünen
haben wir gerade erst auf ihrem
Parteitag beschlossen dass nur zwei AKW
ohne Emsland über das Jahresende
hinauslaufen sollen die Laufzeit aller
drei verbleibende AKW ist dafür aber nur
bis längstens 15 April vorgesehen das
ist wiederum genau das von den Grünen
gesetzte Ausstiegsdatum darüber hinaus
will der Kanzler ein Zitat
ambitioniertes Gesetz zur Steigerung der
Energieeffizienz vorlegen und wer auf
2030 vorgezogene Kohleausstieg in nor
Westfalen wird im Gesetz festgeschrieben
die beiden letzten Punkte dürften dann
das Entgegenkommen an die Grünen sein
also ein richtiger Kompromiss beide
Seiten müssen Krücken schlucken FDP und
die Grünen was bedeutet das für den
Koalitionsfrieden naja also in der Tat
sind es Zumutungen für beide Streithähne
also für grüne und für die FDP die
Liberalen müssen hinnehmen dass die AKW
schon im kommenden April vom Netz gehen
dafür müssen die Grünen den
Weiterbetrieb des dritten AKW
akzeptieren beide Parteien müssen also
Positionen aufgeben die Grünen aber mehr
als die Liberalen das ganze könnte
dennoch die schmerzbalance gerade so
noch halten also so sehr dass nicht eine
Partei so stark einknicken muss dass sie
aus der Koalition aussteigt es war
allerdings auch allerhöchste Eisenbahn
für diese richtlinienentscheidung denn
Olaf Scholz hatte den akw-streit
zwischen den beiden anderen
Koalitionspartnern viel zu lange laufen
lassen was dann dazu geführt hat dass
ich Grüne und FDP nur noch tiefer
eingegraben hatten in ihre jeweiligen
Positionen des Kanzler Machtwort kommt
ist jetzt in letzter Minute denn diese
Woche ist die letzte parlamentswoche des
Monats des
Atomausstiegsgesetz muss im Bundestag
geändert werden damit überhaupt die
Möglichkeit besteht AKWs über den 31.12
hinauslaufen zu lassen Dankeschön Theo
Koll
gehen wir jetzt in die Ukraine dort
haben russische Angriffe die Menschen in
Angst und Schrecken versetzt vor allem
in den großen Städten für viele begann
dort auch diese neue Woche im Schutzraum
in Kiew hat es Tote und Verletzte
gegeben Thomas Gonsior berichtet
morgen grauen ein Einschlag erschüttert
die Hauptstadt Kiew unter Feuer auch
hier detoniert ein fluggeschoss früh am
Montag genau wie vor sieben Tagen ein
Wochenstart mit Attacken aus der Luft
und wieder trifft es Wohnhäuser wieder
Zivilisten inmitten von Schwaben aus
Asche und Schutt Bergen die Helfer tote
auch ein junges Paar die Frau war im
sechsten Monat schwanger
verletzte sind in Trümmern entkommen
maßloser Schrecken bleibt
die Wohnung bei mir nebenan wurde
getroffen verdammt ich hatte noch nie so
viel Angst
wir sind hierher gekommen denn meine
Mutter sagte am Telefon ich bin unter
Trümmern helft mir jetzt ist sie nicht
mehr erreichbar
Einsatzkräfte suchen nach Überlebenden
sie finden auch Reste etlicher
Kampfdrohnen mit denen Russland Angriff
auf einer steht in Handschrift für
biagorod in der russischen Grenzregion
hatte es am Wochenende tödliche Angriffe
gegeben Moskau sagt die Ukraine sei
verantwortlich die Attacken heute eine
Vergeltung sowie vergangene Woche für
eine Explosion auf der krimbrücke
unklar klar nur viele der Drohnen sind
vom Typ Shahid 136 hergestellte im Iran
eine sogenannte
kamikaze-drohne die sich mit einer
Sprengladung aufs Ziel stürzt Polizisten
sollen sie vorher abgeschossen haben die
meisten von 38 Drohnen ein mögliches
Ziel verfehlten die Russen das
Heizkraftwerk
lassen unsere Stadt die wollen ohne
Heizung lassen unsere Stadt ohne
Lebensmittel
Infrastruktur und Versorgung wieder
Ziele auch anderswo im Süden etwa
Nikolai ein Lager für Sonnenblumenöl in
Flammen und aus Moskau heißt es erneut
alle Ziele getroffen an einem Tag mit
toten Zivilisten
ein russisches Kampfflugzeug ist in ein
Wohnviertel der russischen Stadt Jays
stürzt das Verteidigungsministerium in
Moskau erklärte beim Start habe ein
Triebwerk Feuer gefangen ein
mehrstöckiges wohnhausgerät in Brand
Angaben über Opfer gibt es noch nicht
die Hafenstadt jetzt liegt am Asowschen
Meer und so nah an der Ukraine das von
dort Luftangriffe gestartet werden
können
damit sich die Ukraine noch besser
verteidigen kann haben die
EU-Außenministerin und Minister heute
beschlossen bis zu 15.000 ukrainische
Soldaten in der EU militärisch
auszubilden zudem ging es bei dem
Treffen um den Iran es wurden Sanktionen
gegen iranische Sicherheitsbehörden
verhängt weil sie mit Gewalt gegen
demonstrierende vorgehen und auch der
Einsatz offenbar iranischer Drohnen
durch Russland war Thema Isabell
Schäfers die EU-Außenminister zeigten
sich heute besorgt wegen der
Drohnenangriffe auf die Ukraine das
Russland womöglich auch Drohnen
iranischer Bauart verwendet wird nicht
ausgeschlossen
wir werden nach konkreten beweisen einer
iranischen Beteiligung suchen der Iran
streitet das bisher
abanische Drohnen anscheinend genutzt
werden um Kiew zu attackieren das ist
eine Grausamkeit auf die wir einer
Antwort finden müssen
weiteres Thema die anhaltende Gewalt
gegen Protestierende im Iran darauf
haben die Innenminister eine erste
Antwort gefunden 15 regierungsnahe
Einzelpersonen und Organisationen werden
mit einreisesperren belegt ihre Vermögen
in der EU eingefroren wir benennen dort
definiert diejenigen die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass Menschen das
insbesondere Frauen die nichts getan
haben als wir Ihre Rechte zu streiten
dass die umgekommen sind das betrifft
Akteure der sogenannten Sittenpolizei
aber es betrifft auch die anderen
Verantwortlichen allerdings wurde heute
auch deutlich dieses Sanktionspaket wird
wohl nicht reichen
ich glaube die allmächtigen in Iran
müssen mal auf den Kalender schauen und
Sie sehen dass wir 2022 sind die
Menschen wollen nicht mehr eingesperrt
sind darum muss die Europäische Union
jetzt diesen ersten Schritt machen ist
das was wir tun können aber ich fürchte
das nicht der letzte man werde die
Situation in Iran beobachten weitere
Sanktionen nicht ausgeschlossen
gehen wir direkt in den Iran in der
Hauptstadt Teheran ist für uns Jörg
Brase Jörg wie reagiert die iranische
Führung auf die Strafmaßnahmen der EU
also dass iranische Außenministerium hat
erwartbar harsche reagiert man
bezeichnete die Entscheidung der
Europäer als interventionistische
Maßnahme und spricht dem Westen im
Allgemeinen die Legitimation ab sich in
innere Angelegenheiten des Iran
einzumischen der Sprecher des iranischen
Außenministeriums kündigte dann auch an
dass man auf diese Sanktionen der EU
unmittelbar und gleichwertig reagieren
wolle was er damit genau meinte das
sagte er nicht aber er sagte dass dieser
aktuelle Disput keiner Auswirkungen
haben würde auf die laufenden
Verhandlungen sowie der Einsetzung des
atomabkommens dazu sagte er sah Iran
weiterhin bereit wenn diese Sanktionen
nun das die iranische Staatsführung
empfindlich treffen ich glaube das kann
man sicherlich bezweifeln ich denke die
Sanktionen sind eher ein Symbol eine
Nachricht an die Demonstrierenden in
Iran da hatten sich ja viele beschwert
dass die EU sie nicht unterstütze dass
man nur Rede aber nicht handle jetzt
gibt es zumindest dieses erste
Sanktionspaket aus Teheran Jörg Brase
dankeschön
und in heute live gleich um halb acht
sprechen wir mit einer bekannten
Aktivistin und einer politik-expertin
über die Lage miran in der ZDF heute App
und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
in Belgien hat die NATO ihr jährliches
atomwaffenmanöver begonnen zur
Verteidigung des europäischen
bündnisgebietes auch die Bundeswehr ist
beteiligt die NATO selbst besitzt keine
nuklearen Waffen und verlässt sich vor
allem auf die USA deren Atomwaffen auch
im rheinland-pfälzischen Büchel Lagern
weitere in Belgien den Niederlanden in
Norditalien sowie auch in der Türkei den
NATO betont die Übung sei keine Reaktion
auf den russischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine
in Großbritannien soll der neue
Finanzminister Jeremy Hand Ruhe in der
Regierung von List Trust bringen mit
einer 180 Grad Kehrtwende kassiert er
jetzt fast alle Steuersenkungspläne der
Premierministerin dieser hatten an den
Finanzmärkten große Turbulenzen und
einen Kurs Rutsch des britischen Pfund
ausgelöst
Priorität habe die Wiederherstellung der
Stabilität zu Hand
Premierministerin Trust steht in ihrer
Partei massiv unter Druck einige fordern
ihren Rücktritt
Schweden hat einen neuen Regierungschef
und rückt nach acht Jahren
sozialdemokratischer Führung nach rechts
der konservative Olaf Christa schon ist
mit knapper Mehrheit vom Parlament zum
Ministerpräsidenten gewählt worden dafür
war auf die Unterstützung der
rechtsradikalen Schwedendemokraten
angewiesen morgen will Christa schon
seine Minderheitsregierung aus moderaten
Christdemokraten und liberalen
vorstellen
[Applaus]
fast jeder zehnte corona-infizierte geht
trotz Erkrankung zur Arbeit so eine
Studie der Betriebskrankenkassen pronova
BKK die konkreten Ergebnisse 9 % der
Erkrankten erscheinen bei einem
mildenverlauf und trotz positiven Tests
im Büro oder im Betrieb 17 Prozent
arbeiten von zu Hause aus weitere 17%
bleiben ein paar Tage zu Hause bis die
schlimmsten Symptome vorbei sind
und die Pandemie hat auch bei
Grundschülerinnen und Schülern Spuren
hinterlassen egal ob Lesen Schreiben
zuhören oder rechnen die Defizite sind
laut einer Studie besorgniserregend
Beispiel Mathe
bundesweit erreichen 22 Prozent der
Viertklässler selbst dem Mindeststandard
nicht extreme Einbrüche gibt es im
Vergleich zu 2011 fast überall Sachsen
und Bayern erreichen aktuelle dem Fach
noch die besten Ergebnisse
Schlusslichter Berlin und Bremen Eva
Schiller berichtet aus Baden-Württemberg
wie stark das Leistungsniveau sinkt
erlebt Lehrerin Nina Zuchowski in
Stuttgart hautnah ihre Schüler
überwiegend mit Zuwanderungsgeschichte
sacken in Deutsch und Mathe jedes Jahr
etwas weiter ab und Corona hat sie
zusätzlich zurückgeworfen es war schon
sehr schwer zu Hause ohne Hilfe so
richtig zu arbeiten weil meine Mutter
musste ja auch arbeiten alleine wenn man
halt was nicht versteht dann kann man
halt irgendwie dann sitzt man halt
Stunden daran und
das bringt dann auch nichts mehr wenn
denn jemand helfen kann bei sozial
benachteiligten so das Studienergebnis
sind die Bildungslücken besonders groß
aber das Niveau sinkt insgesamt
bundesweit verfehlen 19% der
Viertklässler den Mindeststandard beim
Lesen beim Rechnen sind es 22% bei der
Rechtschreibung sogar 30 Prozent
gleichzeitig wird aber auch deutlich
dass die Kompetenzen der Schülerinnen
und Schüler nicht erst in der Pandemie
gesunken sind wir sehen diesen Trend
seit 2011 das heißt seit zehn Jahren wir
brauchen hier eine Trendwende fordert
die Bildungsministerin gleichzeitig will
der Bund aber Zuschüsse für die
Sprachförderung an Kitas streichen dabei
wäre es wichtig dass Kinder vor der
Schule Deutsch lernen findet Lehrerin
Zuchowski insgesamt muss dieser Trend
nach vorne gehen dass man wirklich von
vornherein und möglichst früh eine
Förderung ja anbietet dass es eben gar
nicht zu diesen Defiziten kommt
inzwischen haben 50% der Kinder in
Baden-Württemberg einen
Migrationshintergrund Schule müsse sich
besser auf diese Realität einstellen
bereits zum zweiten mal in diesem Monat
streiken die Pilotinnen und Piloten der
Lufthansa-Tochter Eurowings knapp die
Hälfte der Flüge viel deshalb heute aus
und 17.000 Passagiere waren betroffen
wie hier in Hamburg die Vereinigung
Cockpit fordert unter anderem längere
Ruhepausen und will die maximale
Dienstzeit in den Cockpits verringern
das letzte Angebot von Eurowings hatte
die Gewerkschaft als unzureichend
abgelehnt der Streik dauert noch bis
Mittwoch an
kurz vor Beginn der Frankfurter
Buchmesse ging es heute wieder darum wer
den Deutschen Buchpreis bekommt
ausgezeichnet wird daher der beste
deutschsprachige Roman und das ist
diesmal blutbuch von Kim Delor Inken
Klinge stellt uns den deboro-man und Kim
deloreson vor Kim
[Musik]
lorison scheint es kaum zu glauben sein
Roman blutbuch wird ausgezeichnet zum
zweiten Mal geht der Deutsche Buchpreis
in die Schweiz erstmals an einen
non-binären Menschen der sich also
keinem der herkömmlichen Geschlechter
zugehörig fühlt das blutbuch hat uns
fasziniert und provoziert in seiner
Radikalität es findet mit einer großen
sprachenergie neue Formen Formen für
eine non binäre Geschlechtsidentität und
das trifft mitten ins Herz unseres
Zusammenlebens die erzählfigur in
blutbuch heißt Kim und ist weder Mann
noch Frau wie die Person die den Roman
geschrieben hat doch sind sie eins
biografisches und erdachtes verschmelzen
in einem Brief an die Großmutter die an
Demenz erkrankt ist es geht um
Erinnerungen an die Kindheit die
Traumata der eigenen Familie und die
Auseinandersetzung mit sich selbst und
dem eigenen Körper Kim de lorison
experimentiert dabei der Sprache sanft
und zurückhaltend mal drastisch und klar
das Schreiben ist eigentlich wirklich
wie das Leben selbst schrecklich und
schön und alles dazwischen
es ist auch
Möglichkeit zu heilen aber auch Wunden
zu schlagen und deshalb müssen wir sehr
genau schauen welches Sätze sagen wir
und welche schweigen wir sechs Bücher
schafften es bis in die Schlussrunde
allein dadurch erhalten Sie alle
besondere Aufmerksamkeit Kim deloresonce
extravaganter Roman hat sich
durchgesetzt
Royale Glanz heute auf Schloss Bellevue
Spaniens Königspaar Philippe der sechste
und frauleih tizia sind zum Auftakt
ihres dreitägigen Staatsbesuchs zu Gast
bei Bundespräsident Steinmeier dieser
lobte die engen Verbindung zu Spanien
auch in Krisenzeiten beide Länder
könnten sich aufeinander verlassen so
Steinmeier anschließend legten die
Royals eine ganz an der neuen Wache
nieder und gedachten der Opfer von Krieg
und Gewalt morgen geht es weiter zur
Eröffnung der Buchmesse nach Frankfurt
und jetzt kommen wir zur
Fußball-Bundesliga Norbert da gab es ja
gestern zwei echte Spitzenspiele
allerdings fangen wir mit Union an die
Köpenicker haben ihre Tabellenführung
verteidigt durch einen 2:0 gegen den BVB
die Borussen die wissen sich nach frühen
Rückstand die Zähne aus an einer
wirklich eisernen Berliner Abwehr
ein Ausrutscher von Dortmund Torwart
Gregor Kobel leitet den unionssieg ein
Jannik Haberer ist da zum 10 nach 8
Minuten
nachlässiges BVB-Spiel geht auch dem 2:0
voraus wieder ist es Haberer er ist
erstmals Doppeltorschütze in der
Bundesliga wir waren da wirklich sehr
scharf im Spiel waren griff wie kommen
in die Zweikämpfe natürlich haben wir
auch ein bisschen profitiert von diesem
1:0 das 0:2 noch wett zu machen wie
zuletzt gegen die Bayern gelingt den BVB
diesmal nicht auch weil Frederick grönow
zwischen den Berliner Pfosten steht
Union bleibt Tabellenführer jetzt schon
an fünf von zehn Spieltagen
und der da Pillen zweite aus Freiburg
der trat in München an ja und musste
dort eine 0:5 Klatsche einstecken 5
bayern-tore von fünf Spielern den Anfang
nach des herrscht gnabry in der 13
Minute das schönste Tor des Tages das
3:0 von Leroy sané im Zusammenspiel mit
schokomoting in der 53 Minute jetzt sind
die Bayern tabellens weiter sané
verletzte sich später Muskelfaserriss im
Oberschenkel und fällt für mehrere
Wochen aus
und das spannende 3:2 der Kölner gestern
gegen Augsburg und überhaupt alle Tore
alle Highlights des Spieltags zu sehen
bei ZDF heute.de und in der ZDF heute
App ja und ein ganz besonderes
Sonntagsspiel das gab es gestern auch in
der Premier League schwächelnde
Liverpooler gewann knapp gegen den
Meister aus Manchester das Tor des Tages
für die Reds durch Stürmerstar Mo Salah
in der 76 Minute danach viel Hektik im
Spiel ein Foul am Liverpooler wurde
nicht geahndet Trainer Jürgen Klopp
rastete an der Seitenlinie aus ja und
zwar dafür die rote Karte
City bleibt trotz der Niederlage zweiter
Liverpool jetzt immerhin Achter
Dankeschön Arbeit und für alle die ans
Büro gefesselt waren und es heute nicht
raus geschafft haben haben wir noch
diese Bilder der goldene Herbst macht
seinen Namen gerade alle Ehre in vielen
Regionen wurde es richtig warm 26 Grad
meldete Stuttgart viele haben dann noch
mal ordentlich Sonne getankt zum
Beispiel im Café perfektes Wetter zum
Energiesparen
ob es so sommerlich bleibt das erfahren
Sie gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal läuft um 21.45 mit Marietta
Slomka auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute löste sich der Nebel
hier in der Poebene und auch an der
Donau rasch auf von Nordwesten kommt die
Kaltfront von die Freiheit heran und die
brachte auch schon etwas Regen mit davor
aber wo das richtig warm für Mitte
Oktober ungewöhnlich warm mit bis zu 27
Grad hier an der Saale mehr als 25 Grad
gab es am Oberrhein die Kaltfront wird
jetzt in der Nacht weiter nach Südosten
ziehen dann regnet es zwischen der
Ostseeküste und der Mosel hier im
Nordwesten lockern die Wolken schon
wieder auf und im Alpenvorland bildet
sich die Kanäle unter den dichteren
Wolken in der Mitte sinken die
Temperaturen auf 14 bis 12 Grad kühler
wird es hier in Südosten mit 9 bis 7
Grad und morgen ist es nicht mehr ganz
so warm wie heute uns erwarten 15 Grad
an der Schlei und 24 Grad am Oberrhein
am Vormittag sieht die karlsrund weiter
nach Südosten da kann es total kräftiger
regnen im Alpenvorland muss ich Nebel
erstmal auflösen freundlich ist es
dagegen schon an der Küste bei Westwind
nachmittags dreht auf Nordwest damit
zieht die Kaltfront weiter in Richtung
Südosten es kann auch mal ein Gewitter
dabei sein am Mittwoch wird es nach
Nebel sehr freundlich bei uns am
Donnerstag kommen von besten Regenwolken
heran und die breiten sich am Freitag
dann weiter aus guten Abend